die junge marie steht im mittelpunkt von
jonas alexander us horrorfilm wenn er
niemals stream mit unheimlicher präsenz
spielt sonja suhl die außenseiterin die
etwas mysteriöses in sich trägt
das blasse mädchen lebt noch im haus
ihrer eltern in einem dänischen dorf
unter ihrer haut zeichnet sich der
ursprung eines schreckens ab der sich
erst allmählich enthüllt
die männer wissen es nicht recht an zu
stellen sich eine distanzierte schönheit
heranzumachen trotz aller anziehung von
ihrer sexualität geht eine gefahr aus
ich wusste dass ich vorher
arbö setzt auf stimmungen und auf die
identifikation mit einer figur deren
körper von einer gewalt heimgesucht wird
die nicht von ihr ausgeht damit folgt
der der dramaturgie der neueren
schauerromantik des nordeuropäischen
kinos mit herausragenden vertretern wie
beispielsweise lars von trier für den
anbau bereits gearbeitet hat
die hauptdarstellerin sonja suhl ist
stärker als alle spezialeffekte sie
spielt alle dimensionen einer frau die
sich selbst nicht versteht aber ahnt
dass die gewalt die sie in sich trägt
etwas ganz und gar illegitimes hat